Hoy quiero hablar sobre--
Me han pedido que mire a lo largo, y voy a decirles lo que
yo pienso son los 3 más grandes problemas de la humanidad
desde este largo punto de vista.
Algunos de estos ya han sido nombrados por otros oradores
y eso es alentador.
Parece ser que no es nada más una persona
la que piensa que estos problemas son importantes.
El primero es -- la muerte es un problema.
Si observamos las estadísticas,
los números no nos favorecen.
Hasta ahora, la mayoría de personas que han vivido, también han muerto.
Aproximadamente el 90 % de todos los que han estado vivos ahora ya han muerto.
Así que la tasa anual de mortalidad suma unos 150.000 --
perdón, la tasa diaria de mortalidad -- 150.000 personas por dia,
lo que es un número enorme para cualquier estándar.
La tasa de mortalidad anual, entonces, se torna en 56 millones.
Si sólo miramos a la primordial y mayor causa de muerte -- envejecimiento --
representa apenas dos tercios de todos los humanos que mueren.
Eso suma un total de muertos anuales
mayor a la población de Canada.
A veces, no vemos un problema
ya sea porque es muy familiar, o porque es muy grande.
No podemos verlo porque es muy grande.
Yo pienso que la muerte puede que sea ambos, muy familiar y muy grande
para que la mayoría de la gente la vea como un problema.
Una vez que piensas en eso, ves que esto no es estadística.
Estos son -- a ver, ¿cuánto he hablado?
He hablado durante 3 minutos.
Así que eso sería, aproximadametne, 324 personas se han muerto desde que he comenzado a hablar
Gente como -- es decir, la gente en esta aula se ha muerto.
Ahora, el costo humano de eso es obvio.
Una vez que comienzas a pensarlo -- el sufrimiento, la pérdida --
es también, económicamente, muy grande.
Yo solo veo a la información, al conocimiento, y experiencia
que se pierde por causas naturales de muerte en general,
y de enjevecimiento, en particular.
Supongan que una persona signifique un libro.
Ahora, por supuesto, esto es una subestimación
Lo que una persona aprende a lo largo de su experiencia de vida
es mucho más de lo que puedes poner en un solo libro.
Pero supongamos que hiciéramos esto.
52 millones de personas mueren de causas naturales cada año
corresponde, entonces, a 52 millones de libros destruidos.
La Biblioteca del Congreso tiene 18 millones de libros.
Estamos indignados con el incendio de la Biblioteca de Alejandría.
Es una de las más grandes tragedias culturales
que recordamos hasta hoy.
Pero esto es el equivalente a 3 Bibliotecas del Congreso --
quemadas, perdidas para siempre -- cada ano.
Así que ese es el primer gran problema.
Le deseo la velocidad de Dios a Aubrey de Grey
y a otra gente como él,
para que traten de hacer algo al respecto lo antes posible.
Riesgo existencial -- el segundo gran problema.
El riesgo existencial es una amenaza a la supervivencia humana, o al potencial de largo plazo de nuestra especie
Ahora: ¿por qué digo que este es un gran problema?
Bueno, primero miremos a la probabilidad --
y esto es muy difícil de estimar --
pero sólo ha habido 4 estudios en estos recientes años,
lo que es sorprendente.
Pensariíamos que sería interesante
tratar de investigar más sobre esto ya que las estadísticas son grandes,
pero es un área muy descuidada.
Pero ha habido 4 estudios --
uno de John Lesley, que escribió un libro sobre esto.
Estimó una estadistica que nosotros
no sobreviremos el siglo actual -- 50%
Similarmente, el Astrónomo Real, a quien oímos hablar ayer,
también tiene una estimación del 50% de probabilidad.
Otro autor no da estimativos numéricos,
pero dice que la probabilidad de fracaso es significativa.
Yo escribí un largo ensayo sobre esto.
Yo dije que asignar menos del 20% de probabilidad sería un error
dada la evidencia actual con la que contamos.
Ahora, las cifras exactas de aquí,
deberíamos tomarlas con un grano grande de sal,
pero parece ser que hay un consenso que el riesgo es sustancial.
Todo quien ha visto y estudiado esto, está de acuerdo.
Ahora, si pensamos solamente en reducir
la probabilidad de la extinción humana en un 1% --
no mucho -- es el equivalente a 60 millones de vidas salvadas,
si solo contamos con la gente que vive en la actualidad, la generación actual.
Ahora 1% de seis mil millones de personas es equivalente a 60 millones.
Así que ese es un número grande.
Si tuviéramos en cuenta generaciones futuras
eso nunca existirá si volamos todos,
entonces la cifra se vuelve astronomica.
Si pudiésemos, ahora, eventualmente, colonizar un pedazo del universo --
la constelacion de Virgo --
tal vez nos tome 100 millones de años llegar ahi,
pero si nos extinguimos nunca lo lograremos.
Entonces, tan solo una reduccion del 1%
en el riesgo de extinción sería equivalente
a este numero astronómico -- 10 elevado a la potencia 32.
Asi que si tomas en cuenta a las generaciones futuras tanto como a la actual,
cualquier imperativo moral de costo filantrópico se vuelve irrelevante.
La única cosa en la que deberíamos concentrarnos
sería en reducir el riesgo existencial
porque, inclusive, la más mínima reducción en el riesgo existencial
sobrepasaría cualquier otro beneficio que esperas obtener.
Inclusive si sólo miras a la gente actual,
he ignoras el potencial que podría perderse si nos extinguiésemos,
aún así todavía tendría una prioridad alta.
Ahora, déjenme hablar lo que resta de tiempo del tercer gran problema,
porque es más sutil y, tal vez, difícil de entender.
Piensa en aquel momento de tu vida --
algunas personas tal vez nunca lo experimentaron -- pero algunas otras,
existen aquellos momentos que han experimentado
en donde la vida era fantastica.
tal vez fue en un momento de gran inspiración creativa
que han tenido cuando entran en este estado de flujo.
O cuando entiendes algo que nunca lo habías entendido antes.
o tal vez en el éxtasis del amor romántico.
o una experiencia estética -- un atardecer o una gran obra de arte.
De vez en cuando tenemos esos momentos,
y nos damos cuenta de cuan buena puede ser la vida cuando estamos en un momento así.
y te preguntas, ¿por qué no puede ser así todo el tiempo?
Te quieres aferrar a esto.
Y luego, por supuesto, se vuelve a la vida ordinaria y la memoria desaparece.
y es muy difícil recordar, en una franja mental normal,
cuan buena la vida puede ser en su mejor estado.
o cuan fea puede serlo en su peor estado.
El tercer gran problema es que la vida usualmente no es
tan grandiosa como podría serlo.
Yo pienso que eso es un gran, gran problema.
Es fácil decir lo que no queremos.
Aquí hay unas cuantas cosas que no queremos --
enfermedad, muerte involuntaria, sufrimiento inecesario, crueldad,
pérdida de memoria, ignorancia, ausencia de creatividad.
Supongamos que arreglásemos estas cosas -- que hicieramos algo al respecto de todo esto.
Fuimos muy exitosos.
Nos deshicimos de todas estas cosas.
Es probable que termináramos con algo como esto.
Que es -- me refiero, es mucho mejor que eso. Quiero decir,
es esto en realidad lo mejor si -- podemos soñarlo
¿Es esto lo mejor que podemos hacer?
¿O es posible encontrar algo mas inspirador para proyectar?
Y si pensamos en esto,
pienso que está muy claro que hay formas
en que cambiaríamos cosas, no sólo eliminando negativas,
sino sumando positivas.
En mi lista de deseos, al menos, seria --
vidas mas largas y saludables, mayor bienestar personal,
capacidades cognitivas mayores, más conocimiento y entendimiento,
oportunidad ilimitada de crecimiento personal
mas allaá de nuestros límites biológicos, mejores relaciones,
un potencial ilimitado de espiritualidad, de moral
y desarrollo intelectual.
Si queremos lograr esto, qué en el mundo, tendríamos que cambiar?
Y esta es la respuesta: tendríamos que cambiar nosotros.
No sólo el mundo que nos rodea, sino nosotros mismos.
No sólo la forma en la que pensamos el mundo sino nuestro ser en sí -- nuestra biología.
La naturaleza humana tendría que cambiar.
Ahora, cuando pensamos en cambiar la naturaleza humana,
lo primero que se nos viene en mente
son estas tecnologías de modificación humana --
terapias hormonales, cirugías cosméticas,
estimulantes como Ritalin, Adderall, antidepresivos,
esteroides anabólicos, corazones artificiales.
Es una lista bastante patética.
Son muy útiles para muy pocos
que sufren de una condición específica.
Pero para la mayoría, no transforma
lo que es ser humano.
y también parecen ser un poquito --
la mayoria tienen este instinto que, bueno, por supuesto que
tiene que haber antidepresivos para los que tienen depresión
Pero hay un sentir raro
de que estas cosas de alguna manera no son naturales.
Vale la pena reconocer que hay muchos otras
modificaciones y refuerzos tecnólogicos que utilizamos.
Tenemos cosméticos para la piel, ropa.
Puedo ver que todos ustedes son usuarios de estas
tecnologias, ¡y eso es bueno!
Se han usado modificadores del ánimo desde tiempos inmemoriales --
cafeína, alcohol, nicotina, reforzadores del sistema inmune,
reforzadores de la vista, anestecias.
Damos a esas cosas por hecho,
pero sólo piensa cuan gran progreso eso es --
por ejemplo, tener una operacion antes de la anestecia no era divertido.
Anticonceptivos, cosmeéticos y técnicas de reprogramación cerebral --
eso suena siniestro.
Pero la distinción entre lo que es una tecnología --
un aparato sería el arquetipo.
Y otras formas de cambiar y replantear la naturaleza humana es muy sutil.
Así que, si piensas en lo que significa aprender aritmética o aprender a leer,
eventualmente estas reprogramando tu propio cerebro.
Estás cambiando la microestructura de tu cerebro mientras lo haces.
Así que, en un sentido mas amplio, no necesitamos pensar en la tecnología
como sólo aparatitos, como estas cosas de aquí.
Pero inclusive instituciones y técnicas,
métodos psicológicos, etc.
Las formas de organización pueden tener un impacto profundo en la naturaleza humana
Mirando hacia adelante, hay un rango de tecnologías
que es casi seguro que van a ser desarrolladas tarde o temprano.
Somos muy ignorantes sobre la escala de tiempo de estas cosas,
pero son todas consistentes con el conocimiento que tenemos
sobre leyes de la física, de la química, etcétera.
Es posible suponer,
dejando de lado la posibilidad de una catástrofe,
tarde o temprano vamos a desarrollar todo esto.
e inclusive con tan solo un par de éstas sería suficiente
para transformar la condición humana.
Así que veamos algunas de las dimensiones de la naturaleza humana
que parecen necesitar mejoras.
La salud es un gran y urgente problema,
porque si no estás vivo,
entonces todas las otras cosas serían de poca importancia.
Capacidad intelectual -- veamos esa caja.
que desemboca en muchas otras subcategorías --
memoria, concentración, energia mental, inteligencia, empatía.
Estas son cosas grandiosas.
Parte de la razón por la que valoramos estas cualidades
es por que nos hacen mejor cuando competimos con otra gente --
son bienes posicionales.
Pero parte de la razón --
y esa esa la razón por la que tenemos bases éticas para perseguir éstas --
es por lo que son intrínsecamente valorables.
Es mejor poder entender más del mundo que te rodea
y la gente con la que te estás comunicando,
y para recordar lo que has aprendido.
Modalidades y facultades especiales.
Ahora, la mente humana no es un procesador unitario de información,
ya que tiene muchas otras modulaciones diferentes y evolucionadas
que hacen cosas especificas por nosotros.
Si piensas en lo que normalmente significa darle a la vida mucho de su significado:
música, humor, erotismo, espiritualidad, estéticas,
importancia, cuidado, rumores, charlar con la gente.
Todo esto es posible por un circuito especial
que tenemos los humanos
pero podrías tener otra forma de vida inteligente que carezca de éstos.
Somos afotunados en tener la maquinaria neural necesaria
para procesar música, apreciarla y disfrutarla.
Todo esto permitiría, en principio, estar predispuesto a la mejora.
Algunos tienen mejores habilidades musicales
y también una habilidad para apreciar música más desarrollada que otros.
También es interesante pensar que otras cosas son --
entonces si todas éstas nos permiten grandes valores:
¿por qué deberiamos pensar que la evolución nos ha proporcionado
todas las modalidades que necesitamos tener
con otros valores que quizas existan?
Imaginen a una especie
que no tuviese esta maquinaria neural para procesar la música
y se quedaran mirándonos con perplejidad
al escuchar una hermosa ejecución,
como la que acabamos de escuchar -- porque la gente hace movimientos estúpidos.
Estarían realmente irritados y no podrían ver lo que nosotros estamos haciendo.
Pero tal vez ellos tengan otra facultad, algo más
que nos pareceria igualmente irracional a nosotros,
pero en realidad a lo mejor se topen con gran valor posible ahi.
Pero nosotros seríamos literalmente sordos a tal tipo de valor.
Así que podríamos pensar en adherir diferente
capacidad nueva sensorial y facultades mentales.
Funcionalidad del cuerpo y morfología y autocontrol afectivo.
Mayor bienestar
Poder cambiar de relajación a actividad --
poder ir lento cuando necesitas hacerlo, y también acelerar.
Poder cambiar de un estado al otro más facilmente
sería algo muy delicado de poder hacer --
poder adquirir un estado de flujo más facilmente,
cuando estás totalmente sumergido en algo que estás haciendo.
Concientización y simpatía.
La habilidad de -- es otra aplicación interesante
eso tendría problemas grandes de ramificación social.
Si en realidad pudieses preservar tu relación romántica con una persona,
sin que disminuya con el tiempo,
eso no tendría que -- el amor nunca de desvanecería si no lo quisieras.
Eso probablemente no es tan difícil.
Tal vez sea una simple hormona o algo que pueda lograr esto.
Ha sido hecho en campañoles.
Puedes aplicar la ingeniería para volver a unos campañoles prairie monógamos
cuando en realidad son polígamos.
Es tan solo un gen.
Puede que sea más complicado en los humanos, pero no tanto.
Esta es la ultima impresión que quiero --
ahora tenemos que utilizar el apuntador láser.
Una forma posible de ser aqui, sería una forma de vida --
una forma de ser, de experimentar, pensar, ver,
interactuar con el mundo.
Aquí abajo en este pequeño costado, aquí, tenemos poco subespacio
de este largo espacio que es accesible a los humanos --
seres con nuestras capacidades biológicas.
Es una parte del espacio accesible a los animales --
como somos animales nosotros, somos un subconjunto de esto.
Y luego puedes imaginarte algunas mejoras de las capacidades humanas.
Habría diferentes modos de ser que podrías experimentar
si pudieses mantenerte vivo por, digamos 200 años.
Entonces podrías vivir vidas distintas y acumular sabidurías
que simplemente no son posibles para los humanos actuales.
Entonces, nos movemos hacia esta esfera grande de sumas
y podrías continuar ese proceso y eventualmente
explorar mucho de este grande espacio de posibles formas de ser.
Ahora, ¿por qué eso es algo bueno para hacer?
Bueno, nosotros sabemos que en este pequeño círculo,
hay estos enormes y grandiosos modos de ser --
la vida humana en su mejor momento es maravillosa.
No tenemos razones para creer que dentro de este espacio más grande
no haya también modos grandiosos de ser.
Tal vez algunos que vayan mas allá de nuestras más salvajes habilidades
inclusive de imaginar o de soñar.
así que para solucionar este tercer problema,
Yo pienso que necesitamos -- lenta y cuidadosamente, con sabiduría ética
desarrollar los medios que nos permitan explorar este espacio.
y encontrar los grandes valores que pueda que se escondan ahí.
Gracias.